the White House is insisting everything
is under control but border patrol is
now warning the southern border could
soon see the largest surge of migrants
in history the title 42 set to expire in
just 13 days now the administration's
setting up migrant processing centers in
Guatemala and Colombia to try and
prevent against agents becoming
overwhelmed border patrol says daily
border crossings could surge to 14
000 daily right now the New York Post
reports 40 thousand people are camped
out just across from El Paso waiting for
title 42 to expire the DHS secretary
Alejandro mayorcas is trying to protect
confidence listen
we do expect that encounters at our
Southern border will increase as
Smugglers are seeking to take advantage
of this change and already are hard at
work spreading disinformation that the
Border will be open after that
High encounters will place a strain on
our entire system including our
dedicated and heroic Workforce and our
communities
the Smugglers propaganda is false let me
be clear our border is not open and will
not be open after May 11th
well Republicans say the response is not
going to cut the mustard and in response
to that just passed a bill that would
reinstate some trump-era border policies
adopt Democrat in the house Hakeem
Jeffries is accusing them of weaponizing
this issue listen
if the Republicans are really interested
in finding a real solution to this
challenge we welcome that conversation
I'm just concerned that too many of the
extreme Mega Republicans have chosen to
try and weaponize the immigration issue
not to solve the problem
but to try to maximize political
Advantage weaponized meaning that
blaming it on President Biden not doing
enough to protect these children that's
correct
uh okay Greg so title 42 is going to
expire in less than two weeks we just
saw some evidence of what I'm about to
point out which is that Congress is the
worst kicker of this can down the road I
mean they
you know chucked their responsibility to
try and secure the Border years ago and
now when we're literally in a crisis
they're spending the last two weeks
fighting about whose fault it is it's
frustrating because you know we do that
we do this topic over and over again and
you listen to Hakeem Jeffries say the
same things over and over again and he's
not even trying we welcome that
conversation why isn't every liberal
always wants to have a conversation and
then when you have a conversation they
don't want to have it but they say we
welcome the conferences present company
uh exclusion no I totally like that yeah
yes and then of course then they
transition
to into extreme AG republicanism which
is who are these people or is it
everybody is it one person please let us
know and then the then the the coup
d'etat weaponizing we're always
weaponizing something right we're I
think we're over weaponizing things
again this is you know this is kind of
like the a block you know it's why isn't
it you know why isn't this a story
because the media has deemed it not a
story we can talk about it but speaking
from my point of view I am not a you
know you know feet on the ground
reporter I'm a you know a talking butt
head I sit here and give my opinions and
then I go drinking so the thing is
reporters aren't doing this because they
don't want to do it so this topic keeps
repeating itself and repeating itself
and then when you come up and you see
this this amazing work from Fox we're
down there you get silence or you get
accusations of xenophobia or even with
racism I think you got to keep busing uh
migrants to Sanctuary cities you know
you gotta have consequences meet the
meet the policies do that until no one's
left
so judge one of the problems here is
when it comes to Congressional inaction
we saw Republicans now for the last two
years ring alarm Bells about a crisis at
the border they've now been in control
of the house for four months this is the
first time they have proposed
legislation to try and secure the Border
again 13 days
it came out yesterday so 14 days before
title 42 expires that does not speak of
a top priority to me well obviously it's
the administration that's got to come up
with the with the answer and if you'll
recall the administration at the house
the Senate and the oval if the Democrats
wanted to resolve this they could have
resolved it but they didn't because it's
a political issue that they can keep
saying that the Republicans are cruel
congresswoman Jaya Powell she says that
the way the Republicans are handling the
border is cruel we need a pathway to let
them in now uh juxtaposed against that
is Mayor Adams now a big Democrat of a
big city coming out and saying I want
FEMA to ban cities from bussing people
into cities so now you've got the
Democrats who are fighting with each
other because look the Republicans right
now are very clear we don't have to come
up with an issue it's against the law to
come here illegally you need a wall all
and you need to be down there to prevent
it you don't need to just let them in 4
million at this point and what I love
about this guy mayorcas who's a liar
also is they're spreading disinformation
that the cartels are spreading
disinformation are you kidding me the
cartels are killing us they're not
spreading disinformation and it's a
strain on our system so what the hell
mayorkas are you gonna do about it you
tell me are you getting more cops at the
border I mean because 40 000 are at
Juarez just waiting to cross
so Jessica to the judges point
Republicans have now made it um
strategic objective to get majorcus
impeached right will that help them
achieve their objectives of securing the
Border
I doubt it it might be something that's
important for this conversation if they
really want to highlight to the American
people that this is someone who has not
been fulfilling his duties if that's how
they feel about it but the best route is
to get some bipartisan legislation and
there are two bills now so there's the
Homeland committee Bill a Homeland
Security committee and the Judiciary
Bill and Betty Thompson who's the
ranking Democrat on the homeland
security committee is pushing back and
saying that you know it cuts all of this
assistance to non-profit groups that
offer migrants humanitarian help but
that seems like something that you could
work out but you do have Republicans who
are also pushing back so Thomas Massey
voted with the Democrats and Tony
Gonzalez a republican in Texas has said
that it's too restrictive on Asylum now
these are all things that maybe we can
find a solution to and then you can get
that through the Senate I don't know but
gone are the days it seems of the gang
of eight or when people really want to
be honest about these things and if we
are going to be honest because that's
what we do here neither party wants to
solve this crisis because everybody
benefits from undocumented labor across
this country whatever state you are in
if there are crops to pick if there are
houses to clean or anything that you can
use people who are living within the
Shadows here in this country to do
people benefit from that and that's
Republicans Independents and Democrats
same argument for slavery typical
Democrat no no no
I'm sorry I
I tell them that I'm not pro-slavery
that's like no but you know what it is
interesting because that is the argument
I mean for slavery is it's like it was a
necessity of cheap labor it's cheap
labor because it's free and in this but
these people super cheap these people
get paid the chance to have a better
life they don't
they're not like forced by crops get
nothing beaten raped Etc right so they
get paid they get housing they got
medication they get education they're
not so much in the shadows I mean
they're like no but I'm not saying it's
not really akin to slavery yeah I agree
with you that removing a majorcus would
do little to change the outcome because
this is the perspective of the
administration the priority of the
administration is not to solve this
problem I also agree with you that at
least one of the parties doesn't want to
solve the problem but it's not the
Republican Party the Democrats do not
want to solve illegal immigration I was
just curious as they said tens of
thousands of illegal immigrants mass at
the border what's this look like
worldwide I just had the producers pull
this article from 2021. 900 million
people worldwide want to migrate 22 of
them want to come to the United States
of America that's 180 million people
that would that's half of our current
population you know if you the cartels
have noticed a reality Republicans have
noticed a reality Fox News has a notice
to reality and if we notice and say the
truth of that reality we're not proper
getting a disinformation we're telling
the world this is what this
Administration has done they've opened
it to a potential 180 million people to
come to this country no interest do they
have in solving this problem well and by
the way we have not seen the real surge
of people which is going to be coming
over the next 10 years which is folks
migrating here from Africa famine
disease
you know continue to ravage that
continent most of what we're seeing is
from Latin America hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else